[Musique]
j'ai toujours été fasciné par la
transformation de matière partir d'un
matériau complètement brut qu'on trouve
dans la nature et lui donner une
fonction bien particulière bien
spécifique
l'entreprise spécialisée dans
l'ameublement de luxe existe depuis 3
ans seulement mais elle tourne bien
[Musique]
leur premier grand chantier a fait leur
renommée c'est un chalet situé à
quelques kilomètres
[Musique]
pendant huit mois Clément et Patrice ont
réalisé tout l'ameublement intérieur
on boit évidemment
c'est la chambre du propriétaire du
chalet on a travaillé sur les sols sur
les habillages muraux sur le bardage en
vieux bois
[Musique]
après l'habillage de la cheminée avec
les restants de d'arbres de l'escalier
en esprit de bois de chauffage rangé
quoi mais
on s'est occupé de tout ce qui est à
l'intérieur en bois
des troncs de bouleau dans la chambre
des enfants et leur chef-d'oeuvre trône
au centre de la maison on avait pas
vraiment d'idées concrètes de la façon
dont on a les réaliser l'escalier et le
souhait des décorateurs et du client
c'était de garder cette écorce comme si
les arbres étaient encore en forêt c'est
quelque chose qui est complètement
unique qu'on n'a jamais réalisé
auparavant et on est un peu parti dans
l'inconnu
[Musique]
avec des
arbres les compagnons ont dû faire
preuve d'imagination
on a choisi les arbres sur pied on a
choisi ce qui nous semblait être le plus
approprié donc de différents diamètres
le plus droit possible et on les a
abattus nous-mêmes on les a passés par
le toit le charpentier nous avait fait
une belle faveur en nous laissant une
partie en attente et après on les a
descendu à la verticale dans le dans la
cage d'escalier
ce chalet est devenu leur vitrine en le
visitant un ami du propriétaire vient de
craquer
un nouveau client donc et un nouveau
défi pour la petite société de Clément
loin des Alpes
à Aix-en-Provence ce client est cadre
dans une grande entreprise de
cosmétiques
en plein cartiste il rénove sa maison du
sol au plafond et il est prêt à y mettre
le prix
donc là c'est une chambre d'enfant de
garçon on doit réaliser une tête de lit
un lit un bureau et un placard dressing
un grand placard dressing on a le bureau
de la famille il est composé d'un grand
plan de travail avec du rayonnage
alors on est dans la chambre parentale
on a une grosse tête de lit surtout ce
mur là à réaliser en plaquage donc on
fait la le design la création c'est
vraiment une des pièces maîtresses donc
c'est plus qu'une tête de lycéen élément
décoratif qui va habiller le mur entier
et là on peut vraiment s'exprimer sur
une PS4
[Musique]
Clément a décidé la fameuse tête
de sa création commence à prendre forme
pour réussir leur gigantesque puzzle les
ébénistes de luxe n'ont pas hésité à
reproduire grandeur nature le mur du
client
cette immense chevet aura demandé à
toute l'équipe plus de 200 heures de
travail on peut pas divulguer le prix
exact de cet ouvrage par respect pour le
client il y a la prestation de
l'éclairagiste et la prestation du
tapissier qui nous a fait tout le
gainage de la tête de lit donc voilà
c'est à peu près entre 10 et 20.000
euros pour avoir un ouvrage de ce type
là
[Musique]
après quatre mois de travail les meubles
pour la maison d'Aix-en-Provence sont
prêts
[Musique]
on a travaillé une des plus grosses
pièces de la maison qu'on a réalisé
c'est l'habillage de cette de cette
cheminée donc c'est en chêne véritable
un plaquage chaîne avec un effet
cannelés
la fameuse tête de lit entièrement créée
par Clément une oeuvre unique qu'il va
enfin pouvoir juger sur place
parce qu'on arrive à poser tout dans la
journée en général ça se passe bien mais
c'est vrai qu'on est pas à l'abri de
petits problèmes techniques
chantier c'est bien connu rien ne se
passe jamais comme prévu je vais checker
le haut là pour le passage du plafond
une position
je sais pas si on va arriver à mettre
l'ensemble c'est un largeur ça rentre
pas dans l'autre sens ça rentre pas donc
après
on espère en démonter le moins possible
mais on sait que on sait qu'on va devoir
le faire
on me rassemble
il faut reconstituer tout le meuble
en bas
c'est parfait
vas-y
pousse encore là
mais ce que Clément attend c'est la
première réaction du client
bonjour
[Musique]
c'est super c'est vraiment c'est
difficile de se rendre compte comme ça
serait sur les bon ça serait sur les
plans et c'est vraiment
le rendu est top
il y a quatre
ouais enfin on avait fait les plans
ensemble enfin c'est surtout Clément qui
avait eu un qui avait eu l'idée du
concept et on avait un peu retravaillé
ensemble donc bon imaginez bien que ça
enfin voilà les boîtes de différentes
profondeurs etc mais le rendu est
vraiment incroyable assez lent assez
magnifique c'est assez exceptionnel de
tomber sur des artisans qui sont
capables de à la fois être bon sur la
créativité sur des pièces comme ça puis
bon après il y a pas que la création et
le dessin quoi il y a toute la mise en
oeuvre qui est extrêmement fine et
minutieuse et enfin c'est parfaitement
exécuté donc maintenant je suis très
très admiratif
voilà ici on a la pièce exceptionnelle
de la de la maison c'est ça qui est top
c'est de passer d'un mur blanc il y a
rien le matin il part au boulot il
rentre le soir et à ça c'est propre
c'est nickel ça c'est top
le carnet de commande de Clément et
Patrice est déjà bien chargé ils n'ont
pas fini de sillonner la France